foreign
[Music]
say he goes that way
standing
projectory
not here
pull down
this side
this way
not here
thank you
so let's close punch boom
close
[Music]
your handsome
his head's already going down
oh yeah
head down I'm not pulling it down
just keeping it down
then project up the arm
s
do not do the obvious of turning him
with your hands making circles okay
so this hand isn't going to make a
circle
this body is moving
it cuts down
they're not going to paint a circle
his arm
hand stays in front of me and I move my
body
it goes down
you see then he's in the right place
then here
don't try to turn him
head this is projecting
through him
same thing here oh
different
okay let's try it
thank you
foreign
again it's very common to think
two-dimensionally X Y okay
and uh
it's not the pattern so if you stand up
if we do tenshinaga we go like this
see he's coming at me and I go at him
okay
the pattern
has him spiraling across the mat as well
as inside my technique so he's literally
his five is gonna go around
his spine's gonna do that
okay
his fine is
[Music]
you see that
so we're here I'm not going to go
this way
[Music]
it's 12 6 o'clock
it's fine
it's gonna go round one
you see at that angle you guys see that
cute
this stuff look how much bass he has
okay
resist
no no
starts the pattern
there
he's coming in to feel that energy
Yin yield
to it Prince
[Music]
[Applause]
get friends get friends
spiral
okay
let's go
[Music]
foreign
you have to create the spiraling cross
geometry in him okay so we're going to
tilt him do you see that but then he's
going to rotate you see that but he's
going to rotate on a spiral do you see
that okay so uh part of his on a spiral
part of his body is going to be in the
corkscrew on one side of that Circle and
his other part is on the other side of
the circle they're not they're not going
to be even that would be a circle okay
so uh maybe I need a hand or two
okay uh here we are like this his test
and I'll tell you what to do his hand is
going to come around his head is going
to come around like that do you see that
I'm not going to try to make his upper
body
go that way
so
you come here and you make this
very slowly you're going to just control
this thing get off the sit
this is the energy of my pattern and my
head control
here it is
the Coq projection do you see that
I don't want his leg to go into
somersault
so I'm not going to make his hand go
that way
I want his hip
to go that way that way okay
so just ever so slowly
bring that head around and out ever so
slowly
but here we're not in contact with the
hip directly but that's the vector we're
in contact with the hand you see that so
I'm not going to push this way so he
does a somersault I'm not trying to
follow the head I'm trying to project
into the hip okay got it so he's going
to turn the head and I push
got you got that okay I'll try to I need
you to pay attention
to how you make a somersault which is
not he's not gonna fall but a resistant
person is not gonna fall okay a trained
July keto dressage Pony walks into the
somersault so they're like thank you
very much okay
so I'm gonna come around
and this head is going this way with the
body you see
but this arm is not going to take that
easy path
this way
it's gonna project that way got it so
here I'll leave that head off I'm not
turning
this is where the arm goes
combine those
see that okay don't bring them
on the same curve
now okay
all right let's try watch for that now
watch for that different vectors
[Music]
not this way
you see it all right it's tapping the
hips
okay can't do a somersault you see he's
doing more of a barrel roll
okay